today we're going to be speaking with
Chris feinen who's the executive
director of the National Coalition
against censorship and also author of
the book How Free Speech saved democracy
uh Chris really great having you on I
appreciate it well thanks I appreciate
you having me you know we've had
conversations about the first amendment
that were very legally oriented and
we've had those often with law
professors and others one of the
interesting things about your book is
that you delve more into the history of
when the suppression of speech and the
fight for free speech were you
contextualize it in history in some
interesting ways and one of the things
you point to just to start somewhere and
we could start anywhere you talk about
war as being one of the big culprits
used by governments to suppress free
speech and I think that won't come as a
huge shock to many in our audience when
we understand the idea of for the
purposes of supporting the troops for
National Security whatever don't say
this or say that that I think will make
sense but can you talk about some of the
examples of when war was used in this
way
sure because actually War World War one
was
um civil liberties meltdown in this
country and actually precipitated
lawyers for the first time to start
thinking about using the First Amendment
to protect speech that the government
might not agree with
um you know the the Sedition Act and in
passed by Congress in
um at the behest of President Wilson
actually provided prison sentences of up
to 10 years for people who spoke out
against the war and it was ultimately
used to prosecute over 2 000 Americans
some for the most inane kinds of
criticisms like Wilson is a blockhead
or people who circulated petitions
um you know the most today what we would
say is the most um
uh frequent forms of speech uh were
suppressed
um and uh and people were sent to jail
over a thousand people were sent to jail
many lives were ruined
um and it was against that background
that
um that the ACLU was formed in 1920 and
um and began to fight and of course you
know in subsequent Wars we would see
um similar efforts at suppression
certainly during the Vietnam war
uh what modern Administration and we can
include the Vietnam War era in that I
mean you know in the last 80 or so years
was most harmful I guess is the word I
would use when it comes to suppression
of speech is the is there a clear
Administration I guess
well yeah Wilson clearly stands out
because
there was so uh there was so little law
actually on the First Amendment before
the 20th century and and there had been
a whole Century before and go you know
go all the way back to the Alien and
Sedition Acts right at the turn of the
the 18th century into the 19th
um newspaper editors were thrown into
jail for criticizing the administration
John Adams
um and um
so
um so there was but there was very
little law on uh First Amendment rights
before
um you know before World War one so and
then you know the
um there were certainly efforts during
the the Nixon Administration around the
Pentagon papers efforts to suppress
right
um you know that very critical study of
the Vietnam War
um you know Daniel Ellsberg was actually
indicted for sharing that with the New
York Times And The Washington Post and
um and might well have gone to jail if
the Supreme Court hadn't stepped in and
said that
um that that was protected speech are
you surprised or I guess what do you
make of how the American right wing
recently has very proactively claimed
Free Speech as one of its core tenets
despite sort of not only having a shaky
history on the subject in the past but
even while claiming uh that as one of
its tenants you know talking about Trump
wants to jail flag burners or open up
libel laws which basically is code for
make it easier to sue newspapers and
media outlets for doing journalism uh is
it is it surprising historically that
you would see that uh seeming uh
conflict and what else do you sort of
think about that
well it's wildly ironic yeah it's wildly
ironic to hear conservatives
um advocating as Defenders of free
speech when over the course of American
History they have been the the major
violators of uh of of that freedom
because they've often you know been in
the majority and the people who have
been advocating for free speech have
been people fighting for equal rights
and that was something that you know
they opposed and
um you know this goes back to the
um it goes back
to the abolitionists and to the women's
women's rights activists and activists
for sexual Freedom
um you know they you know they have
um at every of every turn conservatives
have tried to suppress uh suppress their
speech and right through the civil
rights movement of course and into the
into the modern era and as you say
Donald Trump was a big
um uh you know wave the big stick
against the Press called the press the
enemy of the people
um uh so yes to suddenly see
conservatives advocating you know for
free speech rights is um ironic and also
typical for us because it alienates our
kind of our traditional base which is
young people and liberals and
progressives who have been part of those
equal rights fights there are many
accusations hurled at the left about
suppressing speech including uh
different types of alleged censorship on
college campuses both when it comes to
alleged lack of political diversity
among faculty but also as it pertains to
invited speakers to college campuses has
become a very big kind of Flashpoint to
some degree along the lines of LGBT
discussions most recently when it comes
to trans rights the right will sometimes
hurl allegations at the left what do you
think is the biggest area of concern on
the left when it comes to stifling free
speech
well I think you know I think and that
again is you know a change in the the
political climate
um around free speech
but
um
you know I think that it's
understandable
um in a world that's suffused now with
misinformation and hate speech that
um that people progressives
sometimes tried to suppress speech
themselves and we are concerned about
those efforts on campus and we are
concerned about we certainly support the
right to protest speakers on campus and
to
um and to present the other view but we
really think it's it's a mistake to try
to suppress them because they then
conservatives just turn around and point
to that as justification for the the
suppression that they wanted right yeah
my view on this has been you know an
unsavory guest is invited to a campus
someone I'm not interested in seeing
fine
um if they have been properly invited
and there's no criminal issue and
whatever else certainly inter there's
nothing wrong with the invitation and
the fact that they have an event
protesting outside the event absolutely
fine with it the protesters shouldn't be
restricted to some pen a block and a
half away where nobody sees that be
absolutely fine once the event starts it
does seem to me that it's correct to
allow the speaker to speak and then you
can continue expressing your displeasure
during a q a for example the
Counterpoint will be well there might be
no q a so your only opportunity is while
the speaker is speaking or
um I understand that it starts to get to
one of these things of well you know the
protests can't only be the way
everybody's comfortable part of
protesting historically is sometimes the
protests happen in a way and at a time
and in a place where it is an imposition
on some one else but fundamentally I I
do think that preventing the speaker
from speaking is a mistake
yeah and I think it also applies to
trying to revoke invitations that have
been made to speakers if there are
people on campus who want to hear that
speaker they should have the right to to
hear them but by the same token those
who don't have an absolute right to to
protest and
um but we don't want to you know we
don't want to say Free Speech only for
our side which is really what the
conservatives are saying it's it is free
speech for us
um and and not for you because then that
lays the groundwork for what we are
seeing now around the country which is
these hundreds hundreds of
challenges to books in schools and
libraries the progressives care deeply
about there these are books about race
and the Persistence of racism in America
and how to look at slavery and
um uh in the in the lives of LGBT people
and you know their right to be
represented in school libraries and
um and so you know we can't we have to
protect this is the classic statement we
have to protect the rights of all in
order to ensure that everybody has
rights when it comes to the book Banning
you know the the the truth is I have
researched it is that the right is
overwhelmingly the side that has the
lists of books that should not be in
libraries but very often the right will
hurl back at the left look at what
happened with Dr Seuss they canceled Dr
Seuss Etc to me it does not seem
analogous for a publisher to decide
we're not going to continue new editions
of certain books because some of the
imagery or messaging is outdated based
on current Norms that's very different
than here's a list of 20 books that
shouldn't even be available in the
library from your perspective are these
two very different things or are they
equivalent the way the right States
no I I don't think they're equivalent I
I think that um and they're and the
cases are very slim you know the the
cases that they can point to of
alleged suppression of books certainly
um just don't hold up the the
overwhelming majority of challenges to
books in schools are coming from coming
from conservatives and um and parents
who just don't want their kids or
anybody else's kids to have access to
books that in many cases are are
life-saving because they
they show LGBT kids that they belong
that they are accepted
um and these are you know these are very
important books and also how we present
our history
last thing I want to ask you about
um what do you make of the tie between
actual issues of suppression of speech
by governments and some of the sort of
cancel culture social media Private
Business discussion that now is going on
certainly legally I think at this point
most of us although some people call me
and they don't seem to get this
difference most of us understand that
legally uh Twitter can have terms of
service wherein they don't allow certain
types of statements to be made it's not
a First Amendment issue it has nothing
to do with that that we understand so we
can sort of skip beyond that but
ideologically
and from a principles standpoint when
there is not a legal issue what would an
organization like yours say about some
of the terms of service on these social
media platforms that do limit the things
that are allowed
well we understand
um the power of social media and um and
we understand you know why the decisions
that get made on social media are so
um uh are so important to people we have
we have an Arts advocacy project
ourselves to you know try and push back
against algorithms that are banning all
nudity for example including artistic
nudity from from social media
um
uh but ultimately you know we hold with
the view that that the companies have to
be allowed as as is their First
Amendment right to make decisions about
you know what content they allow and and
don't allow and
um uh you know and and unfortunately at
this point you know there are efforts
underway there are laws that have
recently been passed in Texas and
Florida that are trying to force uh
social media companies to accept content
that they don't want right and that you
know that is a step toward government
you know government intervention in uh
free speech that we just can't we can't
allow that we have to challenge yeah
that's an important point it's
ultimately government intervention
either way uh and that's that's a
critical point we've been speaking with
Chris feinen who's the executive
director of the National Coalition
against censorship the book is How Free
Speech saved democracy which we will
link to from our uh YouTube clip for
this interview Chris really appreciate
your time today
thanks for having me